let's talk about Iraq 20 years after the
U.S invasion
2003 the U.S and a handful of allies
invaded Iraq to get rid of Saddam
Hussein on the premise that he had
weapons of mass destruction well that
turned out not to be true and the war
kicked off a cycle of violence and
political instability that Iraq is still
caught up in I think the legacy is a
destruction of a coherent State and the
inability to rebuild so much has
happened in the last 20 years but we're
going to focus on where Iraq stands
today and how it got there here are five
takeaways to help you understand it all
the first thing you need to know is that
life in Iraq before the U.S invasion was
really tough and that the man who'd
ruled Iraq for more than 20 years Saddam
Hussein was brutal
there was no political freedom and
saddam's regime committed horrific human
rights abuses killings torture
disappearances even a chemical weapons
attack that killed thousands of Iraqi
Kurds
Iraq was isolated seen as a rogue State
and it was under strict International
sanctions that had a punishing effect on
the Iraqi people there was absolutely no
room to barely even breathe the regime
dictates every aspect of your life from
the moment you're born to the moment of
death
but within weeks of the U.S invasion in
2003 Saddam Hussein's regime had fallen
and President George W bush announced
mission accomplished the United States
and our allies have prevailed
[Applause]
despite the huge controversy around the
invasion
it was a moment when some Iraqis thought
things might actually improve
[Music]
Iraqis initially were excited about this
idea like is democracy going to work we
don't like living under Saddam many
Iraqis were actually
cautiously looking at The Invasion as a
potential to end their you know years of
suffering under the Saddam Hussein
regime and the sanctions and all that
[Music]
so then the question became what happens
next and it soon became clear that there
had been some seriously bad planning on
that front so that's our next takeaway
because it set Iraq on a really
troubling and chaotic path
Americans said we are coming for you to
give you a freedom where is the freedom
bombing every day in the night
there is no Administration there is no
system there is no organization
certainly uh U.S leaders could have been
more informed uh about the complexity of
the situation that they were walking
into the U.S installed a temporary
government the CPA and the first thing
it did was a big clear out of people
from Iraq's State institutions it was
called debuffification and it targeted
anyone who'd been linked to saddam's
party the bath party but that was
basically everyone who had been running
the country because you had to be a
party member for most state jobs all the
normal functions of government just
stopped and hundreds of thousands of
people were suddenly out of a job and
then came the CPA's second move
disbanding the Iraqi military and a lot
of people reckoned this was one of the
biggest mistakes so a bunch of men with
guns were now unemployed and angry we
began to see many different malicious
pop-up many different armed groups pop
up many of them would be become the
networks that would become Al-Qaeda and
Iraq and then Isis the plan was
basically
dismantle everything every aspect of the
previous regime all the institutions and
that led to a collapse in security that
Iraq has barely recovered from now
another example of the bad planning was
how the new political system was
designed and introduced it was created
by a bunch of Outsiders mostly American
officials and exiled Iraqis basically
opponents of Saddam Hussein many of them
had lived abroad for decades here they
are at a conference in London three
months before The Invasion where they
agreed on what the new system would look
like to me the fundamental mistake was
people came from outside to a country
and determined that this would be the
political system without really doing
enough
to get to the voice of the people and
how the people wanted to be represented
now in Iraq the three main demographic
groups are the Shia majority and the
Sunni and Kurdish minorities under
Saddam Iraq was technically a secular
state but it was the sunnis who
generally held the positions of power
but the new political system was based
on the idea that the three main groups
should share power there's an unofficial
Arrangement where the Prime Minister who
really runs the country is always Shia
the president is Kurdish and the speaker
of parliament is sunny and that model
served the interests of all those Iraqi
Exiles who designed it and planned to
come back and take charge so how do you
returning to a country after Decades of
Exile build constituents you don't know
these people you don't know any you know
the way you do it is by building these
kind of imagined communities based on
ethnicity or sects all of a sudden you
have these parties come and they're now
creating sectarianism and ethnic divides
and Iraqis are now beginning to find out
from their friends oh I guess my friend
is a Sunni or I guess my friend is a
Shia it never really mattered before now
the other problem with this new
political system is that it's allowed
corruption to flourish it's a huge issue
and that's our third takeaway they call
it power sharing but to a huge extent as
one Iraqi politician herself called it
it's us basically splitting up the cake
most Iraqi is basically will see this
political system as a elite Pact
of these parties that came to share The
Spoils of the state to gut the system of
its wealth the greatest threat to Iraq's
advancement is internal corruption
uh the siphoning of State resources away
from the benefit of the people uh into
personal and private accounts for
personal and private aims keep in mind
there's actually a lot of money sloshing
around in Iraq it's got huge oil
reserves which bring in billions of
dollars every year
and basically fund the government
but it's mostly the politicians who
benefit their fortunes have increased by
billions while the country continues to
decline on
um you know the quality of life on on
income on levels on levels of employment
so the Ministry of Health has this board
to make sure that medicine in Iraq is
fit for purpose its budget is one
billion dollars a year
when we studied it we found that over 70
of medicine is either fake or expired so
people are taking Bad Medicine even
though there is literally a company with
a billion dollars to ensure medicine
right where does that money go it goes
to the political Aid under the system of
of corruption okay the next takeaway if
you want to understand Iraq today is how
Iran fits in because it's a big player
they're neighbors and they share a long
border
in 1980 Saddam Hussein invaded Iran and
the two countries fought an eight-year
War
I think from an Iranian perspective they
fear a strong Iraq thinking largely back
to the time of the Iran Iraq war and
would seek on one way or another to
co-opt Iraq such that it can never
threaten Iran remember Iran is run by
Shia religious leaders it's got its own
Regional Ambitions and a major rivalry
with the U.S which also plays out in
Iraq in the chaos that followed the U.S
Invasion Iran started doing things like
getting behind certain political parties
and funding militias and over time it's
become a major power broker Iran also
does not function as simply a neighbor
it functions kind of as as a protector
and as an owner basically many of the
opposition parties spent time in Iran
when they were opposing this about the
same regime so these you know it
leveraged these relations to really gain
access to how developing the political
system in Iraq to its liking is that
balancing of how to sort of keep Iraq
some strong enough to function but also
weak enough never to present a a threat
to its uh to its interests okay so from
the flawed political system to
corruption to the influence of Iran well
you've got in Iraq today as a kind of
political stalemate where nothing really
gets done add to that the issue of
security or more accurately the lack of
security
the height of the chaos in 2008 around
10 000 civilians were killed Iraqis have
had to deal with all kinds of threats
from foreign troops to groups like Al
Qaeda and isil plus all the different
militias that have cropped up
now sometimes these militias have been
helpful for example in the fight against
al Qaeda and isil
but today it's got to the point where
militias have a kind of Stranglehold
over Iraq and its politics because many
militias are actually aligned with
political parties so there's no real
ruling system
s of parties and
militia groups basically
each other for money and influence and
of course none of this serves the needs
of the people of Iraq which brings us to
our last big takeaway the Rockies are
desperate for change
in 2019 their frustrations spilled over
into huge protests in the south
the protests went on for months and the
government responded with a violent
Crackdown and almost 600 people were
killed
they did bring down the Prime Minister
but they never really touched the system
and instead the system has recalibrated
now many in this protest movement have
pinned their hopes on a guy named
muktada al-sader he's someone you should
know about because he's a very powerful
figure he's a Shia religious leader
who's been around for years he led a
brutal militia that carried out some of
the worst sectarian violence that
happened after the U.S invasion
more recently he stalled himself as a
reformer someone who wants to tackle
corruption and curb sectarianism and the
influence of Iran
but many question alsader's real
motivation or even see him as an
obstacle to reform
alsader's blog actually won the most
seats in the 2021 election but he didn't
manage to form a government it led to a
political crisis that essentially pitted
al-sader against a rival Shia block
that's more pro-iran al-sader's
supporters even stormed Parliament in
the end that other block came out on top
and they chose the current prime
minister Muhammad Shia al-sadani
what all of this shows is just how
difficult it seems to be for Iraq to
move forward the country was so deeply
Shattered by the U.S Invasion and 20
years later
still working out how to put the pieces
back together because we tend to blame
America for everything and yes the
United States does and it should show
the the larger portion of the of the
burden here for invading in the first
place and then not planning for the
aftermath but also Iraqis do share some
of this burden and by Iraqis I do mean
the officials and the leadership
[Music]
check out our last episode on the Wagner
group we've linked it here for you but
you can also find all our other start
here videos on the YouTube playlist
[Music]